et bien bonjour à tous et à toutes
bonjour à celles et ceux qui sont dans
la salle bonjour à ceux qui sont
connectés nous avions choisi cette
horaire de telles sortes que ceux qui
sont aux Antilles puissent pouvoir aussi
suivre la conférence de presse en 14h
étant quand même un horaire compatible à
la fois en outre-mer et à la fois en
métropole
alors l'objectif je vais essayer de
faire relativement court puisque dans le
dossier de presse vous avez un résumé et
vous avez aussi le rapport vous savez
que donc
nous allons parler de l'accordéon qui
est ce pesticide qui a été utilisé en
Martinique et en Guadeloupe entre 72 et
93 pour lutter contre le charançon du
bananier mais aussi qui a été utilisé en
beaucoup plus grande quantité dans tous
les champs de pommes de terre de
l'Europe de l'est de la Pologne en
passant par l'Allemagne etc donc 30 ans
après son interdiction on constate que
cette molécule contamine toujours nos
deux départements en 2009 avec mon
collègue président de l'OPEX le député
Jean-Yves le déo nous avions établi un
premier rapport et 13 ans après ce
premier rapport avec le texte nous avons
choisi faire le point pour évaluer les
progrès
de la recherche des connaissances
scientifiques puisqu'en 2009 nous étions
quand même tout au début des
informations je précise tout de suite
que le fils parlementaire d'évaluation
des choix scientifiques et
technologiques n'a pas pour but et ne
rentre pas dans les questions juridiques
que nous n'avons jamais abordé et je
signale qu'ils n'ont jamais d'ailleurs
été particulièrement abordés avec mes
interlocuteurs qui ont bien compris
qu'elle était l'objectif de ce rapport
tout au long de ces travaux j'ai veillé
à associer le maximum de personnes que
ce soit les scientifiques naturellement
des administrations
le vécu des associations des populations
à travers les associations
à travers donc différentes méthodes de
travail de lopex table ronde audition et
un déplacement en Guadeloupe où j'ai
assisté au colloques scientifiques sur
les rencontres lors des cônes 2022
j'ai présenté ces travaux le 16 février
à lopex et donc vous avez un exemplaire
maintenant il sera publié après cette
conférence de presse
alors le rapport fait tout d'abord le
point sur les progrès de la recherche
ils sont réels mais ils sont encore trop
lents en particulier eu égard aux
attentes de la population
concernant la persistance de la
chlordécone dans les milieux naturels il
y a des bonnes et des moins bonnes
nouvelles dans les bonnes nouvelles en
2009 les scientifiques nous prédisaient
une durée de contamination des sols
entre 350 et 700 ans selon le type de
sol puisque vous savez que ce sont des
sols volcaniques les études qui nous ont
été présentées sont beaucoup plus
encourageantes et démontrent une
diminution de la concentration beaucoup
plus rapide que ce que attendu dû en
particulier au flux pluviométrique le
taux de chlore déconne pourrait être
inférieur aux limites de détection
actuelle
avant la fin du siècle alors ces
prédictions demandent quand même à être
complètement confirmé par la communauté
scientifique mais même
encore 30 ans 50 ans ou 70 ans c'est
long c'est quand même une bonne nouvelle
mais même si la chlordécone disparaît
des sols les eaux douces et maritimes de
par la stagnation dans les roches
acouphènes risque d'être contaminé
encore plusieurs années supplémentaires
après sa disparition
mais sans attendre la disparition
naturelle de la chlordécone les
recherches sont prometteuses
prometteuses en matière de
décontamination alors pour la pollution
de l'eau de consommation vous savez
qu'il existe des filtres à charbon
actifs qui sont performants on a
effectivement observé quelques noms
conformité mais qui devraient
disparaître avec un remplacement plus
régulier et cela
éviterait les interdictions temporaires
de consommation qui conduisent la
population à consommer des eaux de
sources qui sont elles beaucoup plus
polluées et surtout non contrôlée pour
la dépollution des sols les
scientifiques nous ont présenté trois
pistes très prometteuses autour des
souches de bactéries il y a plusieurs
souches de bactéries et les travaux sont
en cours pour stimuler cette dégradation
sur le terrain afin qu'elle soit plus
efficace
deuxième piste des réducteurs chimiques
comme le fer zéro valent ils ont montré
leur efficacité sur la couche
superficielle du sol et ce sur les
terrains martiniquais mais en petit en
certaines quantités de terrain mais il
ne permettent pas de limiter le
transfert de la chlore l'hydrosphère et
avec un coup très important mais c'est
quand même une solution et la troisième
solution ce sont les solutions de
séquestration de la molécule par l'ajout
de compost
certains charbons d'origine végétale
notamment ceux issus des sargas
pyrolysés permettent de réduire le
transfert aux plantes si ça s'avère
efficace ça réglerait presque deux
problèmes donc en 13 ans la recherche a
progresser les pistes de décontamination
semble aujourd'hui possible dans le
rapport nous recommandons qu'elles
soient testées sur le terrain antillais
à grande échelle pour être confirmé et
pour ne pas susciter de faux espoirs
mais aussi pour que les nouvelles
molécules que les scientifiques
découvrent et qui sont issus de la
dégradation de la chlordécone face
l'objet d'analyse sur leur éventuelle
dangerosité parce que si en effet la
peur déconne peut-être
en tout cas ouverte est cassée il faut
pas que les nouvelles molécules soient
aussi dangereuses que la précédente
en 2009 nous avions insisté sur
l'importance d'effectuer une
cartographie complète des sols mais
celle qu'on a pu constater en 2022 n'est
que partielle parce que le choix était
fait de les faire reposer que sur les
analyses gratuites qui sont proposées
aux agriculteurs et aux utilisateurs de
jardin de jardin familiaux
cependant il y a un certain nombre de
méthodes qui permettent aux agriculteurs
de limiter la contaminée contamination
de leur production d'abord vous le savez
seuls les légumes racines et les
turbercules sont impactés par un sur
éclore déconné donc les agriculteurs
peuvent adapter leur culture en fonction
de la contamination des parcelles et
produire autre chose que des légumes
racines ou des tubercules et puis les
fruits n'ont jamais été concernés par la
claire déconne
pour l'élevage les études ont prouvé
qu'un animal pouvait être décontaminé
avant son abattage on le déplaçant sur
une parcelle non polluée et ou dans un
élevage hors-sol par exemple pour les
bovins et un outil d'aide à la décision
qui estime la durée de décontamination
nécessaire à partir d'une prise de sang
a été développée justement pour les
bovins bon le gros point noir demeure
les produits de la pêche mère ou eau
douce bah les seuls solutions sont donc
bien toujours les mesures d'interdiction
dans les zones polluées
ces études sur la pollution des aliments
ont permis d'élaborer des conseils de
prévention à destination des
consommateurs le programme Jafa qui date
et qui a été lancé en 2010 a prouvé son
efficacité puisque des campagnes de
contrôle ont montré que les risques sont
relativement limités pour tous les
produits alimentaires
issus des circuits officiels il fait
aussi de la pédagogie autour des bonnes
pratiques comme les plus sages généreux
des légumes le principal axe de progrès
pour ma part je pense concerne le
contrôle de tout le circuit informel les
légumes les volailles les œufs qui sont
issus de l'autoproduction ou la vente en
bord de route ces contrôles sont
inexistants alors qu'il me qu'un
accompagnement des consommateurs
seraient essentiels pas simplement sur
sur les circuits officiels de la filière
enfin toujours dans les bonnes nouvelles
les connaissances scientifiques sur les
conséquences de l'accordéon sur la santé
humaine s'améliore progressivement il y
a 10 ans dans le cadre de l'étude canari
90% des adultes antillais avec été
détecté avec de la chlordécone dans le
sang chez 14% des guadeloupeéens et 25%
des Martiniquais la concentration
dépassait la valeur toxicologique de
référence qui est fixé qui est fixé
récemment par lande cesse c'est-à-dire
le seuil au-dessous duquel sur une
longue période le risque d'apparition
des fanées face néfastes pour la
population et jugée négligeable mais la
base de ces études est ancienne de 10
ans et il apparaît nécessaire qu'elle
soit actualisée
ça pourrait être fait grâce à
l'amendement que ma collègue victoire
jasmin a fait voter au Sénat qui permet
à tous les habitants des Antilles de
faire doser la concentration de la
chlore des cône dans le sang il est
souhaitable que ce recours que le
recours à se dépistage soit beaucoup
plus massif qu'il ne l'est actuellement
sachant tous les médecins nous l'ont dit
que la chlordécone dans le sang ne
signifie pas pour autant qu'une maladie
va se déclencher
concernant les effets sanitaires les
études montrent depuis 15 ans confirme
une présomption entre l'exposition de la
chlordécone et la survenue de cancer de
la prostate maladie qui est dorénavant
inscrite au tableau des maladies
professionnelles pour les agriculteurs
et les salariés des bananes pour ma part
je regrette le focus qui a fait oublier
d'autres formes de concert de cancer des
études commencent depuis peu
sur la santé des enfants
l'étude de la corde timoun mère-enfant a
mis en évidence une association entre
l'exposition à la chlordécone et un
risque accru de prématurité mais aussi
l'impact hormonal qui peut interférer
sur le neurodéveloppement du poids et de
la taille des enfants jusqu'à 7 ans même
si dans l'étude d'une cerve donc vous
avez pris connaissance le professeur
multinier que nous avons naturellement
auditionné nous a signalé que c'était
fait était relativement modérés et les
impacts sur l'âge péripataire sont
dorénavant à l'étude enfin concernant la
fertilité aucun impact sur l'homme vous
savez qu'au début on ne parlait que du
concert de la prostate et de la
fertilité c'est messieurs par contre
dans ce domaine aussi les études sur la
femme ne débute que maintenant
donc en parallèle de l'actualisation des
connaissances scientifiques notre
disposition
le rapport dresse une analyse un peu
critique que je dirais d'action de
l'État qui s'est manifesté à travers les
plans clore des cônes qui sont succédés
depuis 2008 les trois premiers plans ont
souffert de nombreux écueils et ce n'est
pas que moi qui le signale mais aussi
l'administration les aspects
environnementaux et économiques ont été
négligées le pilotage et le financement
de la recherche
inefficace ce limitant a une meilleure
connaissance des effets sanitaires liés
à l'exposition de la chlordécone c'est
pas mal mais c'est pas suffisant les
instances de gouvernance trouvent
centralisés administrative et avec une
faible association des autorités locales
et une communication grand public
inefficace
ces différentes défaillances confortent
le sentiment de colère et de défiance de
la population antillaise ce qui se
traduit hélas par les difficultés
d'adhésion au dispositif et aux
recommandations alimentaires qui elles
pourtant s'avère efficace
le plan que leur déconne 4 veut tirer un
certain nombre de ses enseignements je
dirais simplement espérons qu'il sera
enfin efficace il a associé dans les
laboration dans son élaboration les
instances et dans les instances de
gouvernance les collectivités locales
les représentants de la société civile
des organisations professionnelles et un
coordinateur interministrés a été créé
et le budget augmenté et un tiers de ce
budget et enfin consacré à la recherche
avec un appel à projet uniquement
consacré à la claire déconne ce que je
réclamais depuis de très nombreuses
années chaque année à tous les ministres
de la recherche quel qu'il soit plus de
transparence aussi avec la publication
annuelle du bilan du plan et enfin des
actions de formation pour les
professionnels de santé les enseignants
et les échos délégués sont prévus
j'espère que ceci pourront jouer un rôle
de relais de confiance auprès de la
population
qui a jusqu'à présent manqué
guidé par cet état des lieux que je vous
ai résumé le rapport force 24
recommandations regroupés au cours de
quatre axes la recherche la
communication la chlore d'économie le
suivi et l'évaluation du plan vous les
avez dans les dossiers et je vais en
évoquer certaines mais je vais pas dire
je ne vais pas toutes les commenter je
répondrai aux questions éventuellement
concernant la recherche comme je l'ai
dit elle a progressé la progressé dans
tous les secteurs depuis 2009 même s'il
faut le reconnaître que la recherche
n'est pas et les résultats à la
recherche à la hauteur des attentes de
la population
à noter que la biodiversité a été un peu
oubliée dans tous ses recherches et
qu'il serait temps d'avoir une vision un
peu plus globale une vision one Elf des
impacts de la chlordécone mais aussi que
l'on comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
que l'on s'intéresse que commence à
faire les scientifiques
aux dérivés qui sont nés de la chlore
des dégradation de la grande école
pour moi les solutions de remédiation
des sols continuent à être prioritaires
afin que pourquoi pas on n'attendent pas
la fin du siècle pour que la chlore des
cône disparaisse le financement du Plan
4 doit surtout être poursuivi faut pas
que ce soit un coup d'épée dans l'eau et
une coordination des projets me paraît
indispensable et j'en profite même si
aucun d'entre eux est là pour féliciter
les chercheurs qui ont été peu nombreux
sur ce créneau j'en ai retrouvé certains
que j'avais rencontré il y a 13 ans et
qui n'ont jamais abandonné alors que il
n'avait pas de financement et qu'ils ont
eu énormément de difficultés
il m'a paraît primordial d'avoir une
vision plus complète des risques
sanitaires sur la population comme je
l'ai dit le focus sur le cancer de la
prostate et la fertilité des hommes à
retarder toutes les études sur les
femmes hormis l'étude timoun femme
enceinte et autre point si même si les
recherches sont complexes les effets
cocktails avec les autres pesticides
utilisées sont maintenant pour moi une
priorité heureusement les connaissances
actuelles fournissent de nombreux outils
pour prévenir la contamination et
minimiser les risques sur la santé
humaine encore faudrait-il trouver les
moyens de convaincre la population de
s'approprier ces solutions le rôle des
acteurs locaux est essentiel car eux
connaissent les réalités et les freins
socioculturels des Antilles la
communication doit absolument sortir du
cadre qui a été le sien jusqu'à présent
sur ce qui pourront servir le médiateur
de confiance
quant à la chlore de l'économie je le
rappelle ce n'est pas un outil prédictif
mais un outil de dialogue avec la
population qui peut rassurer des
antillais et surtout adapter au cas par
cas les recommandations sanitaire en
fonction des résultats de chacun les
résultats obtenus devraient permettre
d'actualiser les données sur la
contamination de la population qui date
de plus de 10 ans enfin j'estime que les
deux il devrait avoir une approche plus
convergente de la chlore d'économie
puisque c'est pas la même pratique en
Martinique et en Guadeloupe chacun a des
bonnes pratiques mais si tout
convergesse ça serait encore mieux enfin
l'évaluation externe a mis parcours du
plan 4 devra vraiment être conduite pour
effectuer les réorientations nécessaires
à temps
je conclurai ainsi ce qui est arrivé aux
Antilles doit servir de modèle à l'état
pour apprendre à gérer les pollutions à
venir que nous ne manquerons pas de
découvrir jusqu'à présent la liste des
erreurs était plus longue que celle des
actions efficaces une vision globale à
long terme s'appuyant sur la recherche
et associant tous les acteurs et la
population est dorénavant nécessaire
pour toutes les futurs pollutions
voilà c'était je vous ai fait le résumé
de ce rapport j'espère avoir pas été
trop longue et je m'apprête à répondre
aux questions je précise que s'il y a
des questions vraiment très techniques
je suis accompagnée de mon
administration Aurélien anno qui est
chimiste de formation et qui pourra
répondre aux questions les plus pointues
à ma place
qui souhaitent commencer
monsieur Roger monsieur
tout d'abord un élément de surprise
quand vous parlez vous avez rappelé que
en ce qui concerne la cartographie des
sols celle-ci n'avait porté que
sur les
évaluations gratuites en faveur à la
demande des agriculteurs ou des
personnes qui souhaitant cultiver leur
jardin comment vous expliquer que depuis
2009 il n'y ait pas eu
on dispose toujours pas d'une
cartographie complète des sols j'ai un
peu de mal enfin je pense qu'il y a un
problème de coût il y a peut-être un
problème de droit de propriété a-t-on le
droit d'aller faire les prélèvements
dans une propriété si le propriétaire le
demande pas
ensuite je me souviens parfaitement
qu'en 2009 et même maintenant en 2022 il
est clair que a priori seuls les
endroits où il y avait des bananerais
pouvait être polluées et pas ailleurs
mais ce choix a été fait par
l'administration et effectivement je
crois que pour rassurer la population
qui serait important de faire des
prélèvements partout y compris dans les
zones qui sont pas polluées parce que
les Antillais se posent des questions
sans compter que dans une salle comme
celle-ci vous pouvez avoir la pollution
à l'accordéon là où je suis et peut-être
pas à quelques mètres puisque c'est
vraiment la chlordécone on l'a posé au
sol au pied d'un bananier et elle est
restée dans les mêmes endroits
une autre explication alors quand on
avait avec Jean-yves le déo demandé
qu'il y ait une cartographie complète
des sols
on nous avait dit que beaucoup des sols
des bananes n'existaient plus puisque il
y avait eu
beaucoup de construction d'habitation et
que c'était parfois difficile d'aller
trouver mais le choix d'origine c'était
de travailler sur les anciennes
implantations des bananes il y a que
comme ça que j'explique et je dois dire
que quand on a recongère reposé la
question j'ai pas eu le sentiment que
l'on voulait
aller vraiment faire un recensement
complet de tous les sols on m'a expliqué
que c'était inutile alors j'ai petit
temps mais bon je pense que la
cartographie plus complexe rassurer les
populations
la recommandation numéro 11 et
extrêmement précise en fait ça m'a
interpellé il est question d'actualiser
les recommandations alimentaires
notamment concernant la consommation de
et de volailles est-ce que vous pouvez
nous oui alors je me suis permis
d'insister là-dessus parce que il y a
qu'en 2022 que j'ai entendu parler des
œufs
jusqu'à présent j'avais toujours entendu
il fallait pas manger des écrevisses là
les wassous fallait faire attention
bovin il fallait faire attention aux
ports qui jouissait mais j'avais jamais
entendu parler des œufs et
a priori effectivement peut-être que
cette information doit passer plus
facilement dans la population vous savez
enfin j'ai le peu que je sois où je suis
allé aux Antilles j'ai aucun lien avec
les Antilles le pot quelques années j'ai
vu des poules qui se promenaient un
petit peu partout comme moi dans mon
enfance de la campagne et bien ces
poules elles font des œufs et
effectivement si elles ont été picorées
dans des endroits où il y a de la
chlordécole les œufs peuvent être
contaminés
et comme la consommation alimentaire des
Antillais c'est effectivement les
produits naturels les légumes tubercule
les poules les œufs etc les poissons je
crois que il y a peut-être un accent à
mettre sur cette contamination
possible pas forcément possible
y a-t-il
des questions monsieur
oui oui c'est pour pour l'enregistrement
en tout cas
ma question était très simple c'était de
savoir pourquoi est-ce qu'on avait mis
autant de temps à se poser la question
pour les femmes et des maladies qui
pouvaient se développer pour les femmes
pourquoi on avait été autant centré sur
les hommes pendant autant de temps alors
j'avoue que c'est une approche qui est
personnelle mais c'est un constat là on
commence on commence à parler alors je
dis pas qu'on a commencé en 2022 à faire
des études
hormis les études sur femmes l'étude de
timoun sur les femmes les enfants le
cordon ombilical le lait maternel qui
peut être contaminé mais on n'a pas fait
d'études sur les autres cancers les
cancer de la femme et d'autres cancers
là ont été lancés je sais plus quand
Aurélien mais très récemment des études
sur un certain nombre de myélome
mais pas auparavant je crois enfin pour
me souvenir en tout cas les débuts
de la grande crise entre guillemets où
on a parlé de la chlore d'école dans les
années
2007 2008-2009 on a tout focalisé sur le
cancer de la prostate et je pense que
les chercheurs d'abord ils étaient pas
très nombreux à travailler sur sur le
plan médical et sur d'autres plans
scientifiques sur la chlordécole ils se
sont d'abord concentrés sur le cancer de
la prostate en cherchant les
comparaisons
en essayant de voir ce qui se passait et
ce n'est que là cette année l'année
dernière où Monsieur muntinier le
professeur multinier nous a dit que ça
expliquait cette 5 à 7% ou 7 à 8%, je me
suis pas de surplus le cancer de la
prostate pouvait pour survenir de
l'accordéon ils peuvent aussi survenir
des effets cocktails de plusieurs
pesticides parce que comme on est
terminé que c'est l'accordéon donc c'est
un autre pesticide où c'est des effets
cocktail
en matière de toxicologie
en tout cas il y a 13 ans il y avait
quand même peu de toxicologues qui
existait en France donc
ces effets cocktails n'ont pas sont
compliqués à mesurer je pense que les
équipes médicales
n'étaient pas très nombreux et
comme je l'ai regrettais les plans les
appels à projets de la NR ont rarement
porté sur la chloricole on a choisi de
temps en temps il y a eu
la nerf me répond aussi on l'a financé
quelques projets mais on sait pas
comment ils ont été choisis et surtout
ce qui m'apparaît c'est que la chlore
déconne a quand même toujours
été une priorité puisqu'on a fait des
plans chlordécone depuis alors comme je
dis c'est à traverser tous les tous les
courants politiques
Chirac Sarko
[Musique]
Macron et le début de la crise c'est
Hollande donc ça a traversé tous les
gouvernements mais on n'a jamais eu un
vrai financement de la recherche et pour
la recherche c'est un petit peu c'est
comme l'âme maintenant que ça va être
lancée c'est la recherche de la
disparition de l'accordéon dans le sang
dans là mais c'est aussi la recherche
médicale et c'est aussi tous les autres
effets sur l'environnement ça n'a jamais
été lancé jusqu'à présent
merci dans les dans les solutions en
termes de décontamination des sols vous
évoquez le fait de séquestrer donc la
molécule avec le compost et notamment
l'utilisation des Sargasses qui
régleraient tous les problèmes
finalement
en tout cas c'est une piste qui semble
bien fonctionner qui a été testé sur sur
le terrain sur une petite surface
c'était qui pour les vous me l'avez vous
me l'avez écrit mais
c'est qui
saragasse pas
donc qui a été ouais ouais à petit
échelle et pour tous les les trois que
ce soit l'aspect microbien ou autre je
trouve que maintenant il faut que ça
passe sur des grands terrains à grande
échelle pour qu'on vérifie que c'est
possible ou pas possible je vous ai
parlé du fer valent bon les essais ont
été réalisés sur une parcelle de 1000
mètres carrés dans la place de Lamentin
c'est déjà pas mal et sur deux parcelles
à glaçante mais passons à des grandes
gestuelles et le projet biochard à
partir de Sargasses c'est un projet ANR
qui s'appelle le pyrossard donc
coordonnées par Sarah Gaspard et les
expériences ont été en laboratoire
uniquement mais avec de la terre et des
sargass es locales
et des essais sont maintenant programmés
sur les petites parcelles alors je les
espoirs que je porte dans la recherche
me disent il faut pas donner des faux
espoirs à la population il faut qu'on
les teste et qu'on était sur le terrain
à grande échelle mais je ne critique pas
les chercheurs c'est que jusqu'à présent
ils ont jamais eu les moyens de le faire
j'ai eu pendant 10 ans des contacts avec
des équipes de chercheurs que j'avais
qu'avec Jean-Yves Le Léo nous avions
rencontré qui m'écrivait parfois ça me
rendait malade madame on a besoin de tel
matériel on a besoin de 15000 € et on
les a pas pour faire les recherches
c'est pour ça que je
critique le fait que la recherche n'est
jamais été financée parce que un
chercheur cherche il trouve pas
forcément mais si on lui donne même pas
les moyens de chercher mais on trouvera
jamais rien
oui vous avez dit que vous avez signalé
que vous voulez pas vous exprimer sur
des sujets juridiques mais néanmoins
est-ce que votre travail
comment est-ce que vous vous positionnez
par rapport aux demandes d'indemnisation
que formule la population antillaise je
me je ne me prononce pas sur
ces formules d'indemnisation parce que
je vous dis j'ai travaillé sur l'aspect
scientifique je suis pas une juriste
j'ai beau être sénateur je suis pas
juriste et pas là-dessus ça mène à tout
la preuve
donc je me formule pas je trouve qu'il y
a eu une première étape qui est faite
avec la reconnaissance des maladies
professionnelles mais aussi la
reconnaissance il y a un autre système
pour les enfants et autres on a commencé
à faire des
on a commencé à faire des recherches
mais et des indemnisations mais
indemniser toute la population
je dirais que le préjudice il est
en tout cas un préjudice d'anxiété c'est
clair comme je le disais tout à l'heure
vous pouvez être dans une zone qui est
absolument pas contaminée et être tout
aussi inquiet que quelqu'un qui est dans
une zone contaminée et qui toutes les
façons décident que il continuera à
vivre comme il a vécu jusqu'à présent
mais je n'ai pas j'ai pas d'autres j'ai
pas d'autres positions
je me permets simplement de donner une
analyse enfin qui n'est pas juridique
mais qui est la mienne entre dire que
c'est parce qu'on a prolongé de trois
ans entre 90 et 93
la l'utilisation de l'accordéon c'est
pas ça qui a changé les choses parce que
quand on sait que c'est prévalent et que
ça reste dans le sol pendant 100 ans
trois ans de plus ou trois ans de moins
ça change rien c'est plutôt aller mais à
l'époque avait-on les éléments
pour savoir que la chlordécone était
aussi dangereuse et pouvait rester dans
le sol j'en sais rien
mais c'est comme
je dirais que c'est comme la méiante
ça a été utilisé alors qu'on aurait pas
dû l'utiliser
mais peut-on refaire le passé avec
l'approche de l'avenir ça j'en sais rien
je suis pas comme je vous l'ai dit je
suis pas une scientifique
ce ne sont que que mon approche
enfin deux personnes qui quand même
s'intéressent à cette pollution et à la
corde depuis pas mal d'années
alors
juriste mais vous vous recommandez des
choses un peu comme une sociologue en
disant que ça serait bien d'essayer un
de mobiliser les sciences humaines et
sociales pour saisir les problèmes
sociétaux posés par cette contamination
et donc lutter contre la défiance de la
population quelle forme ça peut prendre
ça cette mobilisation des sciences
sociales ce que vous préconisez nous
avons eu en audition des sociologues
effectivement ils m'ont ils m'ont ils
nous ont bien expliqué je dis nous ont
bien parce que plusieurs de mes
collègues assistaient aux éditions
expliqué qu'elle était ce sentiment de
défiance et d'angoisse de la population
qui est
quand vous êtes pas sur place vous ne
pouvez pas le mesurer
il y a vraiment une défiance de la
population vis-à-vis des conseils et des
conseils sanitaires
ces conseils sanitaires et alimentaires
particulièrement font que la population
qui suit les conseils sanitaires
c'est-à-dire qui existe depuis 13 ans
manger que deux ou trois fois les
légumes racines par semaine si vous êtes
dans un seul pollué
là maintenant on dit de bien éplucher
comme Monsieur le disait on va leur dire
faire attention aux oeufs et ainsi de
suite la chlorelecom disparaît
si on mange plus d'aliments dans la
chlordécole et donc c'est pour ça que le
la chlore d'économie
si elle est vraiment faite et elle
grande échelle va permettre de savoir si
les Guadeloupéens et les Martiniquais
sont toujours autant
entre guillemets avec leurs déconner qui
a 10 ans mais ça on le sait même pas on
se base sur les chiffres il y a 13 ans
mais l'alimentation est quelque chose
d'essentiel et
suggérer
je crois à l'année à la NSM je leur ai
dit pourquoi pour essayer de convaincre
la population je crois pas que ça vienne
de nous il faut que ça vienne du terrain
de prendre
une série d'étudiants qui traitent les
Antilles pour venir
pendant passer pendant un an
une scolarité en métropole là c'est sûr
qu'ils vont ils mangeront pas d'aliments
que leurs déconner et de mesurer de voir
effectivement si leur déconnes disparaît
parce que quand vous mangez pas
d'aliments compte tenu de la demi-vie la
durée de demi-vie la chloricole en un an
et demi ou en deux ans vous avez plus de
clandé comme dans le sang et donc je me
dis innocemment que ce serait des
antillais et on pourrait voir quelle est
la peut-être convaincre ceux qui ne
veulent pas croire que changer leur
alimentation
peut faire disparaître de l'accordéon
fonctionne ils ont trouvé une idée pas
idiote mais ça veut pas dire que moi la
faire
et donc pour revenir sur l'origine de
votre question je pense que des
sociologues
des gens de terrain qui connaissent bien
la population
il devrait pouvoir trouver les moyens
de communiquer et de communiquer comme
on l'entend et en passant je pense par
par des équipes locales par des gens
qui vivent comme tout le monde
c'est pour ça que les efforts qui sont
faits par rapport à l'information de la
population
des enseignants ou les formations des
professionnels des médecins me
paraissent important
on nous a évoqué par exemple un
médicament contre qui permet de faire
disparaître la chlordécone mais on nous
a expliqué en même temps que ça ce sont
que dans les cas
très grave parce que les effets
secondaires sont presque plus importants
que les effets leur déconne or il s'agit
pas non plus
de pouvoir de que les médecins donnent
prescrivent de la chlord de ce
médicament contre la chloricole alors
que sa justifie pas et qui peuvent avoir
finalement des maladies plus graves
qu'en ayant de la cliente dans le sang
parce qu'on ne sait pas vraiment
qu'est-ce que ça provoque la chlore
l'école hormis ce pour l'instant ces
cancers se surplus de cancer pour cette
pour cent de la population
juste en conclusion 13 ans après le
premier rapport que vous avez rendu sur
ce sujet qu'est-ce qui a changé évolué
c'est positif les perspectives oui je
suis plus optimiste en particulier par
rapport à la recherche parce que la
recherche a quand même progressé et
comme je dis elle a progressé alors
qu'il y avait pas encore de financement
donc vraiment bravo et félicitations
chercheurs
la recherche médicale commence à faire
orienter vers d'autres formes mais
faut-il qu'il y ait des résultats je
dirais un plan le plan que lors des
comics
dire les conclusions des échecs des
précédents mais est-ce que ça veut dire
que pour autant il sera efficace je
l'espère en tout cas il est un peu plus
en matière de moyens et de moyens
financiers et d'association de la
population mais
ce qui a été fait jusqu'à présent a été
fait par les administrations centrales
et à mon avis
que ça soit conçu par les
administrations centrales peut-être mais
il fallait que ce soit vraiment repris
au niveau local ce qui n'a pas été le
cas et je voudrais simplement revenir
sur j'ai évoqué
la chlore d'économie entre
la Guadeloupe et la Martinique dans une
des îles c'est uniquement sur
prescription médicale on peut aller se
faire faire l'autre
île c'est tout le monde peut la faire
comme on veut dans une île c'est
en fonction des résultats le médecin ou
labo va accompagner la personne en lui
disant vous avez des traces qui sont un
film c'est pas dangereux ou vous avez
la couleur la couleur des cône il
faudrait que vous fassiez attention à
votre alimentation à votre eau
et dans l'autre île on donne les
résultats mais on ne donne pas ce
commentaire je crois que les deux
pratiques sont bonnes mais elles
devraient ça ouvert à tout le monde et
avec un accompagnement individuel pour
que les gens puissent mesurer si si ça
évolue ça n'évolue pas on a deux ARS
c'est vrai que les choix ont été faits
avec les collectivités locales
territoriales mais j'ai entendu en tout
cas quand les trois jours où j'étais en
Guadeloupe certains qui se posaient la
question pourquoi ça fonctionne pas de
la même façon sur les dossiers et que la
population peut se dire pourquoi moi
j'ai besoin d'un certificat médical ou
l'autre moi j'ai mes résultats mais je
sais pas ce que ça veut dire
aucune question sur Internet
et bien
madame non
je vous remercie chacun et chacune
d'avoir été présent surtout ne vous
intéresser à ce sujet je nous sommes
très contents au Sénat qui est une
trentaine de
journalistes qui sont qui sont ça
m'intéressait par ce sujet c'est un
sujet que j'en ai discuté un tout petit
peu hier soir avec le président d'archet
il estime essentiel important vous savez
que au Sénat on a depuis très longtemps
il y a des groupes qui s'intéressent à
eux qui sont spécialisés qui
s'intéressent à l'Outre-mer et qu'on a
voulu mélanger
sénateur de l'outre-mer et sénateur de
métropole pour les engager dans ces
préoccupations en tout cas le président
l'archet qui s'est rendu il y a trois
semaines un mois aux Antilles me dit à
chaque fois je suis Madame Claude mais
il me dit à chaque fois c'est important
c'est essentiel il faut suivre il faut
faire quelque chose donc merci à vous
tous et sachez que au Sénat en tout cas
le dossier que l'on déconne et la
pollution au clan d'école est une de nos
préoccupations
merci à vous